[Music]
foreign
of the after show today we are going to
be talking about a very very special
film one that's very near and dear to a
lot of people Glass Onion and knives out
mystery they're all friends
why would anyone commit murder
are we even gonna talk about the
elephant in the room am I the elephant
yeah you're the elephant you're not that
bad it is going to be a spoiler-filled
discussion so guys if you haven't seen
the movie watch along no just kidding
watch the movie and then come back and
revisit this chat grab a pineapple juice
whatever pick your poison whatever your
pleasure is and sit back and enjoy our
chat uh I am so excited to introduce our
guests Andreas Cabrera welcome welcome
the host of the meaning of podcasts
welcome we're doing this in person we
are this is crazy I'm so excited
um first of all I'm going to talk about
the Tomato Meter score and the audience
score because it is a match and this
almost never happens 93 Tomato Meter
score
93 audience score of course that means
it is certified fresh and here is the
critics consensus Glass Onion and knives
out mystery brings back Benoit Blanc for
another wildly entertaining mystery
rounded out by an outstanding ensemble
cast so first and foremost let's break
the ice
do you concur with the 93-93 I do concur
I thought you were gonna say you didn't
for a second you the seven percent
indeed not the seven percent I do concur
I I think this movie is an absolute
blast a lot of twists and turns it it
definitely follows up the knives out
kind of traditional storytelling that
Ryan Johnson has created with his own
formula his own style his own Flair into
bringing this new kind of mystery Agatha
Christie kind of Vibes to this new story
but it feels like it still has the same
thematic elements to it and it just has
enough character interaction enough
thematic elements if that makes sense so
I feel like this definitely lives up to
the Knives Out movie franchise now that
we have right I love that we can now I
think we can officially Now call it a
franchise I thought I found it really
really interesting how that movie The
original Knives Out sort of like came
out of the gate and people were so there
was so much surprise in it because it
was really something even though like
you said it's like an Agatha Christie
and he is cited Agatha Christie as his
inspiration many times over for this
franchise but the big question is always
can somebody follow up something that is
such a phenomenon and it is trending it
is constantly an eye a Glass Onion is
constantly trending it's been trending I
I feel like ever since it came out in
the theaters at Thanksgiving and it
keeps going and the different characters
keep going that's hard to do here's the
thing and I was thinking about this
because I've watched it four times now
oh wow and
for many different reasons but when I
watch
the first one and then when I watch this
one and they've the cast has said this
it's not really about the reveal
and what makes I think it's so good is a
couple of things the fact that you can
re-watch it and keep finding Easter eggs
and Fourth Watch I was seeing new things
that I hadn't seen before but something
that is hard to do is an ensemble comedy
and they really lean more into the
comedy this time I felt like but the
Ensemble comedy and I was thinking who
else does an ensemble comedy and the
only one I could really think of was
like Guardians of the Galaxy in a sense
is like an ensemble comedy but also the
fact that it is star studded yes and
that he puts together these casts and
now I feel like and I don't know if you
agree now you're going to have people
calling Ryan Johnson going I want to be
in the next one it's kind of like
bragging rights to be in the next one
yeah I kind of feel like a lot of the
actors in this one wanted to be in this
one because of the first one yeah
because they saw the first one
appreciated it and realized how much fun
it is but also how much you can actually
communicate Within These movies I was
one of the few people who said that the
first one should have gotten a lot more
Awards recognition even maybe even Oscar
recognition to the point now that
finally this one is almost making up for
the first one because now this one is
getting a lot more Awards recognition
and I think the actors in these movies
are realizing wait a minute can I be in
an awards worthy movie and still have a
blast and that's kind of what this movie
is well this is yeah and this is
Netflix's I would say big Awards hopeful
for this award season we're going to get
into it a little bit later because Ryan
was nominated for this original final
screenplay this time it would be an
adapted screenplay which I find really
interesting that it's now considered to
be adapted and I think there was a
little bit of debate about that but for
sure I mean I think people have talked
about Chanel possibly
um but let's let's talk about like what
aspects of the film do you think makes
it work the most I mean I think first
and foremost it's completely original
other than you have a couple other you
know franchises that are doing
murder mysteries but I feel like Nobody
Does it like with this sort of comedy
and the element of modern like it feels
very of the now yeah and it feels very
fresh of course this one he leaned into
so many like contemporary pop culture
jokes and cameos and that kind of thing
and I think when you people spoiled it
for me so I did go into it knowing about
the runner
thing and I knew about this you know the
Serena Williams thing I knew most of the
cameos I knew about the Hugh Grant so it
did take away the element of surprise
for me but what worked for you the most
about this I I really do feel and it
might be the most basic answer there is
but I really do feel like it's the
Thematic elements it's the amount of
social commentary political commentary
satirical commentary that Ryan Johnson
provides in all his movies but
especially in this movie like you said
about the relevancy of it the modernness
of it where it feels like it's
communicating so much about our world
now not just like our world a couple
years ago not just like a big broad
message but a message about what is
going on now when it comes to the one
percenters when it comes to Tech
billionaires when it comes to
politicians all these kind of people who
have a lot of money and who get a lot of
money by usually stepping on a lot of
people I think a lot of people can
relate to that turn on the news turn on
TV this is usually what they're talking
about so seeing a movie kind of taking
down the big dogs the one percenters
and talking about how they are actually
not as cool as a lot of people think
they are not as smart as a lot of people
think they are is something that to me
was so fresh and so relevant and so well
done because it's hard to do right it's
really hard to communicate a message
about today's world and not step on too
many people's toes but Ryan Johnson does
it so well well that's what you just the
reason I was laughing I was not laughing
at you I was laughing because the real
big reason why Benoit Blanc who is such
a you know great at solving Murder
Mysteries and he says this one has
baffled my brain and this one I cannot
figure out and the reason is because he
gave Ed Norton's character too much
credit and the big twist is you're
stupid that's why I couldn't figure this
out I was giving you way too much credit
and that was when it all started to
unravel so he really did but I feel like
as much as he is making a commentary I
didn't really hear much backlash because
usually you get that in the public eye
but I feel like he did it in such a way
that it was in such good fun in good
spirits that nobody nobody got super
offended okay so the big question is
before we dive into the details of the
movie
better the knives out
on par with Knives Out not as good as
knives out I have a very very soft spot
in my heart for knives out the first
time okay I feel like they're it's just
so expertly well done and I feel like
the the originality I've seen it the
first time there's something special
about it there's just something so good
about seeing this done the first time
around that I feel like it's just a
little bit better but this one is I feel
like it's different enough to where the
comparison is there but it doesn't
necessarily line up directly with the
same even tone because a lot of people
have mentioned this but the tone of this
one like you said is a lot more comedic
a lot more like a comedy like an
ensemble comedy worse whereas the first
one featured comedic elements but was
much more centered around the main
character and just the mystery of it all
and this one is centered around much
more as far as miles bronze character
and what he's trying to do and then the
comedy surrounding him with this cast so
I feel like it's just different enough
but I still feel like the first one's a
little better there was something about
the family element of the first one that
you really felt more of the interaction
between all the key players and I felt
like there was more character
development or maybe it was the
performances I'm not really sure but
when I went back and watched it I was
like how is Jamie Lee Curtis not
nominated and I'm a member of the
Critics Choice and I remember voting for
Tony Collette for supporting for that
one and being like she's got to be she's
so but every single performance in the
first one I feel like the characters
were so fleshed out and as a family you
felt they had something vested in each
other or I felt like in this one they're
on this island together and there were
so many times where they were like I'm
so bored I was like first of all I would
not be bored on that island but they
didn't really seem like what they wanted
to be around each other so it makes you
as a viewer go well you know do I do I
want to spend you know do I want to
spend this that time so that that part
for for those reasons and I felt like
the actual murder mystery of it all was
so tightly wound and I loved the twist
at the end with the oh she gave him the
correct medication and Anna um Jah armas
I thought that was a breakthrough
performance to date her best performance
yes and that was the heart of the film
and this one I guess you would say
Janelle Monae was the heart of the film
so how did you feel about let's first
talk about Benoit Blanc and his
Evolution how did you feel
um
you know we obviously find out he has a
boyfriend who he lives with who is Hugh
Grant we see him in a bathtub that I'm
not really sure I wanna like I think
Ryan and and he both said in the first
one we don't want to know Benoit blanc's
backstory we don't want to know who his
parents are there's something about him
being shrouded in mystery and he's just
there to solve the crime where I feel
like we got a little bit more of a peek
into who he was and he was a lot goofier
this time yeah even his wardrobe is a
little bit goofier right
I have a problem with it but you know so
um how did you feel about his Evolution
I I loved it I feel like I know a lot of
people might have complained about this
I saw a little bit of people complaining
as far as this isn't been wall block we
saw in the first movie and maybe that is
the case but I feel like adding a little
bit more Flair adding a little bit more
comedy a little bit more eccentricity as
far as what Daniel Craig is bringing to
this character to me it's him adding
that to it and to me it's also it's kind
of cool I think to see a character like
Ben wall Blanc
B the world's greatest detective a
Kentucky southern guy like having this
weird mix of like genius detective
Southern Kentucky like it's this weird
combination that Ryan Johnson has
created to make this kind of satirical
character as far as what it is to even
be inside this country that we live in
in this class right because I feel like
almost every single little detail inside
knives out and inside Glass Onion is a
commentary on something and I feel like
his character is also a commentary on
what it is to be a Southern Kentucky
race kind of person where he has this
very very thick accent and yet that
accent that we associate usually with
being like Oh you're not as smart it's
like no he's the smartest person in the
world essentially inside this world so I
really feel like that adds so much to
the character and his endearment with
Working Class People with people who
work in Services people like Martha in
the first movie
Janae Monet's character Howlin in this
movie Alabama teachers nurses those kind
of people that Benoit Blanc caters to to
me says a lot about his character and I
feel like Daniel Craig delivers that to
like an incredible level you just so
nailed it and that's something I never
thought about I remember like in the
first one Anna's character he loved her
because he loved her pureness of spirit
and that is something that's that's a
skill to be a be able to suss out a good
person from a bad person and to have
that Affinity
um and I I agree with you I think Daniel
Craig I think Ryan is like do what you
want and Daniel Craig is like
having so much fun and he's talked about
like
James Bond was just he was so done yeah
and I think probably more physically for
the physical demands than anything else
but how many people can actually follow
up huge success in a franchise like that
and turn around and start another
franchise and another iconic character
back to back like that yep you know and
then you think about Ryan Johnson who
also brought in Chris Evans and that
became an iconic character and that
freaking sweater was iconic like it's
it's amazing and he came off you know he
came off Marvel so it's kind of cool the
way he allows because we see a lot of
times these actors who are in franchises
and they get out and they they're like I
just want to do something different
we're like we don't care we want to see
really that one character of the rest of
your life and then they try something
else and it doesn't work right and
you're just go ahead no well to me it's
it's this idea of what I loved about the
first one and what I think this one does
so well as well is the idea of bringing
in these actors who like you said have
done major huge projects before and want
to get into a much more
awards-worthy kind of recognition kind
of movies to really expand their careers
and what's ironic is that they're
choosing this movie in a very comedic
way where they're able to get the same
amount of recognition have the same but
have even more fun probably than doing a
you know if Daniel Craig does like a
really dark and gritty You Know Drama
movie but instead he's doing this and
he's still probably getting the same
amount of awards attention I was
wondering um when I mentioned the
bathtub I'm like I don't know if I
needed to see that
but I think it's it's so funny and I was
do you tell me if you think this is true
or not that in James like as James Bond
there was always a shirtless scene right
he always was coming out of the water
there was always that quintessential
slow-mo was this Daniel Craig's nod to
I'm gonna sit in the tub with like a hat
on my head and be a total geek and have
my boyfriend yelling at me like are you
still in the like is that was that his
kind of homage to I'm not going to be
that guy anymore it could be yeah I mean
it definitely could be I also feel like
it's a match to just what it was during
coping it's very quarantine like a lot
of people were sitting in their time
it just really like Skyping people and
zooming people and just being like you
know what do we do now like we just
played this game so okay so let's talk
about Janelle Monae and her Duality her
um what did you think of her performance
and what did you think of the twist
yeah did you see it coming at all I did
not okay I did not and I definitely I
really liked it I really did feel like
At first it's drawing right because you
hear the thick Alabama accent after we
already met Andy and after we already
see how Andy is acting so once we meet
Helen you're just kind of like what is
happening this is way too much for me
but after a while you start to feel a
lot more endeared towards her and you
realize her motives and her mission is a
lot more righteous than we previously
thought right whereas before Andy being
betrayed by Miles and having this you
know you betrayed me you guys all
betrayed me I'm gonna get revenge that
feels like okay cool we get it but
having her sister trying to seek Justice
for her sister to me is a lot more
compelling than it is maybe a revenge
tour for Andy well and that was a like
it was almost I guess halfway through
the film when it was a complete reset of
the film in a sense because they went
back and I almost felt like when I was
watching it because the um the Andy
character was so angry you know and it
was kind of like where are they going
with it like where is he going to take
this and then when and then they had the
reveal it worked I thought she did a
great job
um do you have a favorite moment
uh yes I would say my favorite moment is
Benoit blanc's final speech the famous
Smiles Braun is an idiot speech I feel
like that entire thing because obviously
the donut within a donut speech in the
first movie Yes is Iconic yeah so it's
hard to follow that up but I really do
feel like this one did in a very
different way where they explained to
you very specifically what Benoit Blanc
has done in his head throughout the
entire time he was on the island which
is break down exactly what is going on
and realizing wait a minute this super
tech genius billionaire is actually not
a super tech genius billionaire he is
just a fake you know uh someone who is
just used to you know BS in his way
through bringing people into his company
and claiming he's the smart guy and
using all these people around him to
make as much money as possible
and then threatening them in the same in
the same breath and him breaking down
exactly what he is and exactly what he's
done throughout the entire movie to show
you that he's actually a fake to me is
just incredible I mean the way he's like
think about what he actually did not
what he told you but what you saw with
your eyes is what he says in that speech
and I thought that was such a powerful
statement considering that's kind of the
world we're living in now where a lot of
people can be like wait a minute I'm
gonna claim one thing and say this is
who I am when in reality that's not what
we're seeing at all and I felt like that
was such a relevant speech to have
nowadays and the way Benoit Blanc just
laid it out with this southern accent
was just perfect and that's sort of the
title Glass Onion like in plain sight is
the thing that he talks about
um one of my favorite moments and it's
going to kind of lead me into the next
question was actually a cameo was Ethan
Hawke when when everybody's on the dock
and he shoots everybody in the mouth
with whatever was supposed to cure
everybody from covid and Benoit is the
only one that kind of questions it and
he's like what are you putting in my
mouth and he's like you don't need that
mask anymore and he goes you're good
yeah you're good when he said I mean
talk about having like there's no small
roles that he had how many lines in the
movie three and that scene there was so
much in it I also just love the way that
was shot and part of what I liked about
the way this what he did with this film
and I don't know if he necessarily did
it with the last one but Ryan talked
about this what's the cinematography
where he would have like especially on
the dock when you saw Benoit and then
you would see all the players behind him
sort of like getting on the boat he
would shoot somebody an extreme close-up
and then there was a reveal behind them
and there was even a shot
um there was a shot at the pool scene
where Janelle's character was at the
pool and Kate Hudson's big hat was sort
of covering her up and then it kind of
there was a lot of sort of like smoke
and mirrors like the reveal the big
reveal and it was just it was a
technique that sort of adds to that uh
murder mystery element where things are
hiding or lurking and it kind of when
the first time you're watching it you're
like is that a clue is that a clue I
have a question though and then I'm
going to ask you your favorite cameo the
kombucha explained the kombucha was it a
red herring as far as like she kept
chugging and I was sure something was
going to happen like there was going to
be a Twist at the end that there was
something in the kombucha but she kept
chugging it but then it was just sort of
like a plug right yeah I feel like that
was just mainly to show you that she was
just confused as far as like what these
high-end products are right as far as
like alcoholic kombucha and stuff like
that like she wasn't used to that kind
of stuff so yeah because I was just I
was watching it going this is a clue
this is definitely a this is a clue so
what was your favorite Cameo oh uh
probably
Serena Williams
I thought it was hysterical I thought it
was so funny to see her just like I mean
the first time I saw her and you see her
turn around and just be like are we
gonna work out guys it's like are we
doing something or not like this is your
money your time I thought that was
pretty funny and we have to give a shout
out to Hugh Grant yeah I think he's the
internet's favorite yes like people have
been he's sort of having a Renaissance I
feel like and this is you know hopefully
we're going to see more of him down the
road I think Daniel has said like he
would love to do more and have
more of him and that relationship
um in future films
um so let's go down the line let's talk
about
um some of the different some of the
other players in the film some of the
other characters uh aside from we've
already talked about Janelle's character
and Daniel
who is the next favorite
if you had to choose it's tough right
yeah it's tough because I feel like each
character in this movie like you said in
the first one the first one feels like a
very much like a family kind of
character Vibes whereas this one to me
is a much more broader more archetype
kind of character where it's like the
scientist the governor the streamer the
crazy fashion model like each one has a
very broad General money making career
choice so I feel like one that to me is
a little bit underrated and I'll give a
shout out to is Catherine Han because I
feel like Catherine Han is such a good
actress that I feel a lot of people
forget just how good she is and if you
go back and re-watch the movie you could
see so many details into her acting
choices and the way she's able to
demonstrate her posturing the way she
moves her mask up and down the way she's
able to communicate with different
characters the way she talks to Benoit
Blanc the way she talks to
Leslie Odom's character like she has so
much Flair in such a different and
diverse kind of acting style that she
brings to every character that to me I
feel like Catherine Han is good in
everything she's in like there's no
movie or show that she's not just so
good in you're right because in a sense
like I wouldn't say she's the flashiest
character amongst a sea of flashy
characters in this
but she's seamless like her acting and I
would say the same thing about like
um David Shannon in the last one where
it's almost like not the standout
character but Michael Shannon let me
take that back is Michael Shannon in the
last one where you feel like he wasn't
the standout character but overall when
you go when I went back and watched it I
was like oh you know what I forgot about
him because he's an actor yeah not that
the others aren't
um I want to give a shout out to
Madeleine Klein as whiskey I thought she
was really fun and I think partly
because I guess she's she was in Outer
Banks I haven't really I never watched
that so I don't really know her so to
see somebody come into that caliber of
cast and really hold her own
um and I just think she has that sort of
um she reminds me a little bit of
Florence Pew she's kind of got a little
bit of that Vibe she's kind of got that
cool girl Vibe about her and even though
she's playing you know the hot girl
she's
and she's obviously there's a reveal
that she's very smart when she's talking
to Janelle's character when they have
that one-on-one but
um yeah she was just kind of refreshing
I thought she was really refreshing but
I have to give a shout out to Dave
Batista yeah and I was so pissed that he
died so early because he is a blast
now here's my big question about there's
one that you know everybody is always
doing this when they watch a livestock
movie and I go down a rabbit hole on
Twitter to look for people who look for
holes in the plot where they didn't
think of everything so here's my
question
and I'm sorry to put you on the spot but
you know when miles Braun when he gets
the Google alert before he dies Dave's
character yeah and he shows it to Miles
and that's why miles poisons him because
he realizes that Cassandra is dead right
yes
how did he know he murdered her and that
she didn't commit suicide
because he saw her because he saw him
leaving he saw him leaving but does that
mean he killed her
no because he didn't know when he went
to the house and she didn't respond he
just assumed whatever she's doing her
own thing right but when once he saw
that she came up dead he was he put two
and two together that's Dave's character
yeah Dave's character put two and two
together and was like wait a minute if
he was leaving the house he might saw
him that night and now they're telling
me she's dead
that was just like a week ago she he
must have had in the hand in killing her
is what his kind of head was going to
you know what my head would have done
yeah look everybody oh my God like he
put I mean that was maybe I was putting
um Drax on this character because Drax
wouldn't have done that no but yeah this
character was a little bit savvier and
was blackmailing him from the gecko it
was just like here you're gonna put me
on I think I think he figured it out
once he realized like wait a minute I
saw him leaving the house that was just
last week and now they're telling me
she's dead that was a quick deduction he
should be uh the next Ben Walker he
should yeah too late yeah yeah right
yeah
um
um okay so let's go down the line let's
talk about the rest of the characters we
talked about Catherine Han what did you
think of Leslie Odom Jr's character as
Lionel I feel like he maybe was a little
underutilized in a sense I feel like he
definitely played I think someone else
might have said this the adult in the
room he kind of played the I'm the
serious guy I'm I'm the much more
thinking guy I'm I'm gonna push back a
little bit against miles not too much
you know I still want money but I'm
going to push back just a little bit to
make myself seem like I'm a little bit
more high and mighty than everyone else
yeah I feel like that was his character
where in a way he was just as bad as
everyone else but he himself perceived
himself to be just a little bit more
righteous and a little bit more
realistic than everyone else I feel like
that is his character and I think he
played it really well who would have
been the adult in the room that Knives
Out in the original probably Jamie Lee
Curtis yeah character I feel like yeah I
guess in the end she was right yeah she
was a little bit more the answer for
that I love it what about Kate Hudson as
birdie I feel like she was the one that
kind of a lot of people loved and I feel
like Kate was just kind of playing Kate
I feel like that's her in a sense I mean
she's stupid not bad but they kind of
like yeah you know when she sees
everybody she's personally big
Personality yeah she was definitely the
ditzy kind of comedic you know comedic
tension kind of release as far as the
character goes and just bringing a lot
of joy and fun and funny one-liners too
she had the famous what is reality like
that one came back I thought that was
great like it was definitely the
ignorance is bliss kind of character
where her ignorance is her excuse for
doing horrible things insane horrible
things like thrush and tired yeah
because throughout the entire movie they
make it a point to tell you all the
things she's done is through ignorance
but it still doesn't excuse what she's
done right and what she said where you
know Benoit Blanc has that famous line
where you know you know as far as yeah
that's the line that I think everybody's
talking right because it was incredible
I remember watching that in the theater
in my screening and everyone was like
yeah uh yeah like it really felt like a
uh like a Marvel moment where it felt
like a superhero kind of moment because
the line was such a relevant moment
where he's talking about the the danger
of mistaking speaking the truth with
speaking without thought yeah like it's
a dangerous thing to to mistake speaking
the truth to speaking without thought
and that to me embodied so much of the
message of what this movie's about where
a lot of these characters really do feel
like they're better than everyone else
and that danger of thinking like I'm
just gonna say the truth I'm gonna say
when no one else is wanting to say
because I have this Superior mentality
Like the Way Miles Braun said the
disrupter mentality as far as who did
that work yeah right where it's like you
you have this superiority complex where
you feel like you're better than
everyone else and that thought process
of saying me saying this stuff makes me
better and makes me you know the truth
speaker when in reality it's no thought
it's a lack of thought it's fake it's a
facade and it's it's coming from a place
of ignorance which is exactly what
Birdie's character is yeah and I
remember
um the last film Knives Out
um they sent out t-shirts during award
season that said eat because that
was kind of the line that popped yeah
and it's interesting that I feel like if
there was a t-shirt made that was the
tagline for this one it would be about
that it would be that and it's a totally
different thing it's much more it's a
much deeper message than obviously
but I feel like that was that was the
line and I wonder when Ryan wrote it if
I got to talk to him about it I would
ask him like
did he build a lot of when did that line
come down like was it
early on and he sort of built the story
around or did it come to him as he was
just sort of writing that scene because
it was it's pretty pretty much like you
said sums everything up okay who isn't
okay we haven't talked about Jessica
henwick as Peg smaller role yeah yeah
what did you feel about her I I love her
I really do feel like she I I've loved
her in everything she's in and I know I
already said this about Catherine but
Catherine Hahn but I really do feel like
Jessica is just
this is my small soapbox as far as my
Jessica rant but I feel like Jessica is
so good in everything she's in obviously
she was in Game of Thrones small role in
Game of Thrones small role in Star Wars
her bigger role was in Iron Fist and her
bigger role was in the new Matrix movie
Matrix resurrections where she played
bucks
she is so good in that Matrix movie and
she is so good in Iron Fist and I know a
lot of people don't like Iron Fist but I
feel like
she is such on a come up and she's
making these new movies and she's really
to me reaching this level as far as a
up-and-coming young actress who can
really do some work in Hollywood and
really have some major significant roles
so I I wish we saw more of her but I get
her role which is mainly just being the
assistant and just being there and being
the one on man out on women out yeah as
far as this entire cast of like rich
people where even Whiskey's character
you know could still probably claim to
have a little bit more of this
connection to Miles whereas Peg had no
connection to Miles and Miles didn't
even know her name right right when she
was begging him on the stairs and he
just it was having to he was saying you
are how the hell did you get here kind
of thing okay so let's end things on uh
if we're talking with characters let's
end things on Miles Braun himself Ed
Norton I mean fourth fourth watch
Flawless performance really flawless I
think I mean talk about nailing a
caricature of a type of person without
there's a hammer behind you a Thor
hammer without hitting it over the head
I'm still making it his own like it's
one of those roles where I watch it now
I watched it again last night and I
thought
nobody could have done it better and
that's the kind of that's when you know
you've done a great job is when nobody
could have done a better job than what
you did what did you think he's
incredible and it's one of those things
where Edward Norton is such an
incredible actor a lot of people forget
his role in I think of his role in
Birdman which to me had like a similar
Vibe where he plays this kind of bigger
bombastic character but his
eccentric attitude his smog attitude
that all that he brought to this role to
bring this Tech billionaire to life and
to show you the layers of what he
actually is whereas like when you peel
it back you realize like wait a minute
this guy is not who he says he is and to
me his character had so much commentary
as far as what it is to be in this world
that we currently live in and as far as
what it is to have these billionaires
claim to be these big powerful Geniuses
who are actually not and who are
actually
beneath a lot of people but claim to be
superior than everyone else so to me he
just nailed that you know it's a fun
moment to go back and watch again when
Cassandra comes up on the dock
his face they do a close-up of his face
yeah but when you watch it the first
time you you're they're giving you it's
like what Benoit Blanc says they're
giving you the movie it's in plain sight
in plain sight Ryan Johnson showed you
in that moment who the killer was on my
re-watch I also noticed a few things but
on my re-watch I noticed
um everything is actually there right
where when he says oh he he took my
drink by mistake you see him pass him
the drink on the first watch they don't
do a different cut or they don't do a
different scene to it they show you
exactly what he did they show you uh
Daniel
um Benoit blanc's characters say Helen
when he sees her on the stairs like
there's so many little Clues there and
it's all in plain sight it's nothing
hidden it's all there for when you see
it again you start to realize wait a
minute everything was already here
before and Ryan Johnson just presented
it to you but Dan gave you all this
miles Brawn kind of theatricality to
cover it up when in reality his
storytelling was actually just a
cover-up for what actually happened so
to me it's just incredible what he did
anything that didn't work for you in
this film
um
probably
his small nitpick but probably the
ending when she's smashing the glass
it might have gone on for a little too
long in my opinion I feel like we we got
to the point as far as what the hydrogen
gas was going to do and she was going to
exploit explode the Glass Onion but to
me when she was smashing the glass it
took me quite a few seconds I didn't
know what she was doing I was like
what is going on
is this a statement I'm so glad that you
found is it an effective statement I
don't know I thought it was I was like
when he said you know an ounce of
courage he hands her the glass and he
says this is giving you courage I guess
courage to just smash the crap out of
everything and it really didn't feed
into the hydrogen it didn't hit until
later is my my thing yeah like it kept
going it took a second and then
everybody I guess part of it everybody
else joined in and that's when they
turned they turned on Miles
um so that was it that was anything else
I have a couple
um I mean we kind of talked a little bit
about the characters where I felt like
in the first one the characters were a
little bit more and I know they're not
supposed to be likable so when I say
shallower I don't mean because that's
sort of part of
yeah you're not really supposed to like
anybody in these films but I felt like
there were there was a lot of scenes
where people were just sort of sitting
around not engaging with each other or
in the first one every character had an
active purpose at every second whether
they were going after like when Anna's
character was given the inheritance and
they were going after her and they were
all like how are you doing or there was
always an active like and that's
something I took acting classes way back
and that's when my acting coach taught
me is that you always have to have a
purpose and a scene yeah if you're just
bored and you don't want to be there
that will come across to the audience
and the audience won't be invested you
always have to have something you gotta
get from the other person or out of the
scene or you're something that drives
you so I felt like a little bit of that
sort of they were hanging out the other
thing is just selfishly I love
Destination movies you know I just love
anything to do with the beach like the
beach with Leonardo DiCaprio I love that
movie any destination I wanted to see
more freaking grease they went to Greece
to shoot this thing and a lot of it was
inside yeah so I think I wanted just to
sort of Revel more in like we saw the
Glass Onion that was cool we saw his
tacky room but I think when they first
arrived on the island and they put the
wristbands on us and then they had the
robot go by I wanted to explore more of
this guy's Lair I kind of feel like that
was on purpose though I kind of feel
like the idea of this guy who has it all
and who's literally has a private Greek
island prefers to surround himself with
paintings and art and glass structures
then just enjoy the nature of what it is
to be a rich guy but he'd rather be
inside and play his little game he
couldn't drive his own car yeah like he
put his car in a pedestal I feel like
that was commentary as far as wait a
minute you have an incredible beautiful
fast car but you put it on the pedestal
like you don't even drive it you you
live in a Greek island but you don't
walk around the beach you walk around
inside and play games like to me that
was a little bit more of commentary into
what the miles bronze character is yeah
and I think
part of again the inconsistency for me
was that they they wanted to leave after
a day and yet they would lie under oath
for him so that was a bit confusing to
me like you'll lie under oath and I feel
like Kate Hudson's character was the one
that sort of kissed his butt the most
um where a lot of them just sort of
Express their disdain for him but that
also lends itself to what you're saying
is he kind of passed it by his friends
in a way and do this elaborate mystery
box and whatever and to get them to come
out and then within 24 hours less than
24 hours other than the murder mystery
part of it they're kind of uh they're
kind of kind of bored um here's my thing
okay where do you think he should go
like where do you think Ryan should go
with the franchise moving forward he's
already said they're going to do another
one Daniel Craig says has said he's
signed up for however many more
personally I would love because we know
Ed Norton's character is going to jail
right we know Chris Evans character is
in jail I want them to be cellmates
break out and do like a Bonnie and Clyde
kind of movie they're doing a morbius
vulture team up like Jared Leto shows up
because he mentioned him in this one uh
I I I don't know about that it's like a
villains uh super team I want to I want
a super team up against all the villains
in all of them eventually they should
have like their version of The Avengers
where it's just like a team of like
knives
you can spin wallpaper he put us in jail
um so where do you think do you think
Ryan should just if it's not broke don't
fix it like just go to a different
destination and pick another cool cast
or do you think he needs to switch up
either the tone or whatever like in the
next I mean if there's any theme inside
these movies it's about corruption with
big money right yeah so I feel like we
saw the tech billionaire we saw the old
money when it comes to the first movie
there's so much there to explore I mean
if I'm being selfish because that's kind
of how I am I I kind of want to see a
sports angle to it because there's so
much corruption in sports that I think
it would be kind of interesting to see
maybe a sports cover-up story because
I'm kind of inundated with that watching
ESPN constantly so I see kind of the
corruption in the NFL or maybe soccer or
maybe you know any kind of big sport
there comes to I feel like it'd be kind
of interesting to see a cover-up murder
inside this major sporting event I think
that'd be kind of interesting wow any
Dreamcast ooh
um I don't know
[Music]
um
someone incredible her oh Michael
Fassbender how about that Michael
Fassbender you know what Michael
Fassbender could have been a good miles
Brawn too actually yeah he could have
yeah
he's a great actor he's he's he's
definitely a good one
yeah no people oh yeah he kind of
already did that didn't he well that was
cool that was quick
um yeah no I think I'm kind of of the
mentality if it's not broke don't fix it
like
I don't I think it's working people
obviously love these movies and he's
struck a cultural nerve while doing
films that are possibly going to get
nominations yes you know this film's
probably possibly going to get some
nominations
um and that's just really hard to do
it's really hard to and when you hear
like if somebody had said to you oh I'm
going to pitch you a movie it's an
Agatha Christie
it's sexy right it just doesn't sound
like people have tried it it's kind of
people aren't really loving the murder
mystery genre but he is just crushing it
as long as he keeps those stories tight
with good twists I think it's really
about at the end of the day the story
and the sky's the limit in terms of he
could cast whoever he wants Florence
Pugh I would love to see in one of these
that's a great one Florence Q is amazing
she would love it fantastic I'm trying
to think of somebody as Penelope Cruz
she's one of my favorite actresses I
think she could play a really
interesting
she could almost play the villain I
think that would be really fun to see
her do something like that
um let's talk about award season so
um it's nominated at the Golden Globes
uh for musical or comedy I don't know if
you've had a chance to look at the other
nominees but what do you think its
chances are ooh can I can I do you know
the other nominees yeah we can pull it
up I mean I know the one that I think is
the biggest competition is everything
everywhere all at once oh yeah in that
category so the nominees for the Golden
Globes for musical or comedy are Babylon
banishes of inner Sharon everything
everywhere all at once Glass Onion and
triangle of sadness okay so what do you
think I think it's
it's pretty slim if I'm being honest
really yes that is a shocking twist that
I did not expect here I feel like the
momentum behind everywhere everything
all at once is so big yeah and I feel
like
triangle of sadness is also an
international feature which Golden Globe
has a big connection International
obviously okay critics so that's
probably the second runner-up and maybe
behind that but even then the amount of
Love That Colin Farrell is getting for
Banshees of engineering is huge
it's tough It's very tough the
tough yeah
for a couple of reasons obviously we all
know the Golden Globes took a couple of
years off they changed the makeup of
their body of Voters
um they tended in the past to really go
for
movie stars they love movie stars they
love
yeah they love you know like I mean the
Martian one for best musical or comedy
let's not forget that okay yeah so it'll
be interesting to see this year if they
go in a different direction I feel like
everything everywhere all at once in
past years might not have won I feel
like the sort of way they used to vote
favors Glass Onion because it's a huge
Ensemble movie star splashy enjoyable
movie triangle of sadness I I don't know
if they all you know it doesn't have the
people aren't talking about it as much
Babylon is so polarizing to get me
started and banishes is the other one
but is it
when I hear musical or comedy I feel
like they that almost bordered on drama
sure so I don't know I I think it could
win and let's not forget Netflix is
really
good so I think they could do great
um and then moving forward to the Oscars
so knives out as we talked about earlier
was nominated for best original
I think Ryan's a shoe-in for a
nomination for best adapted
and the other two I don't have all like
obviously the nominees haven't come out
yet but the other two that are sort of
the Front Runners in that category would
be women talking or she said I feel like
Ryan's going to win for this and I'll
tell you why because I think
he
it's it's going to be sort of the body
of work where he's going to win for the
last one and this one together I agree I
think this is a lock for him yeah what
do you think I I definitely feel like
it's up there for sure considering he
I mean this is kind of I feel like this
is his best quality right his writing I
feel like a lot of people can take away
certain things as far as what Ryan does
but his writing is so Stellar so Elite
so well done that I Feel Like It's just
tough to keep up with him so I really do
feel like this is definitely his biggest
opportunity to win do you think it gets
a best picture nominee at the Oscars I
do yeah I do too because I think they're
having 10 for sure this year yeah and it
definitely gets in I agree it's it's got
that you know the Oscars want to be
relevant yes
a makeup for knives out in my opinion
because I I was right as I mentioned
before I feel like Knives Out should
have been nominated for best picture
right I think yeah you know what I
forgot that it wasn't yeah it wasn't
I wanted it to but so again and that's
what the Oscars does is they tend to you
know they tend to make up make up for
you know people win for things that they
shouldn't necessarily back for actress
yeah it's their body of work so I feel
like he's gonna get he's in and yeah it
is a way for them to be cool young
relevant
um at the Oscars I think it's getting in
for sure yeah
um any other nominations you see for it
any other performances or
I mean General money is probably yeah
you know she has a shop but I don't feel
like it's as strong as of a shot as
probably other performances throughout
the year
um but I feel like that's probably
that's probably it
um production design wardrobe maybe
costuming production design
a freaking nomination
can we give his scarf a freaking
nomination
I think it's always hard for actors who
play more comedic roles to get those
nominations but I think award shows
should start to do that and award those
performances because he has crafted a
character that is so undeniable at this
point people want to see more of it as
much as people made of the accent I
can't get enough of it yes I agree I I
really do I really do feel like
when it comes to these types of comedies
right yeah because there's obviously all
different types of comedies but when it
comes to comedies that are able to
balance so many different themes and
still be able to communicate a really
well put together message throughout the
entire movie but still do it in a very
satirical kind of throwback kind of way
yeah it's 100 worthy to me yeah for a
nomination
um
right before we go out I just remembered
my my next favorite moment in this movie
and that was the destruction of the Mona
Lisa herself
[Laughter]
but to voyeuristically think about what
that meant yeah and the genius of how it
tied in from the beginning of him saying
he wanted to be recognized in the same
breath as a Mona Lisa and the fact that
it was his freaking hydrogen that blew
it up yeah how brilliant was that it's
crazy it really was because it really
takes you a minute to realize what is
going on right yeah because at first
you're like okay she blew up the Glass
Onion sure that's not really going to do
much but then you realize the Mona Lisa
was there so when the Mona Lisa burn and
she explains it very well the way Helen
explains it where she's like
your product destroyed the Mona Lisa yes
you're done like your your career
yourself yeah and he needed it spelled
out to him yeah he did he was just kind
of mad he didn't realize his life was
completely over until she pointed out to
him and then the ships came in with all
the sirens and Benoit sat there with his
cigar just enjoyed the moment and she
actually did the Mona Lisa pose and the
Mona Lisa smile at the very end I didn't
catch this someone else told me this
um she did a little pose in the little
Mona Lisa smile on the stairs no at the
on the uh seat at the edge when the
ships were coming in when the police
were coming in
yeah
yeah okay I'm watching it a fifth time
there you go it's incredible it really
isn't it and I'm gonna freeze it and see
if her eyes follow me wherever I go oh
my gosh Andreas this was such a blast
thank you so much yeah this was amazing
it's fun talking about a movie that you
know is a fun movie yeah I really do
feel that and it's cool that it's on
Netflix and that a lot of people can
check it out too and yeah you can watch
it over yeah I can go back I can go home
and watch it there's so many movies now
that people are like you got to see this
I'm like where where am I gonna watch it
but it was also brilliant that they did
that one week theatrical release because
people got to go watch it in a theater
and that was the first time I watched it
like I said somebody did spoil some
things for me but I did see it with a
crowd and it's fun listening to
everybody react to it in that way but uh
remind everybody where they can find you
and thank you so much for joining this
was a blast good to see your face in
first absolutely yes yes thank you so
much Nikki yeah you can find me on
Twitter and Instagram at Squad looterase
and my YouTube channel and podcast at
first cut and I'm Nikki Novak and thank
you all so so much for listening to this
episode of the after show we had a blast
chatting we hope you enjoy your
pineapple juice and we'll see you
hopefully on the next one bye
thank you